all right big knowledge
you know where are you from originally
where'd you grow up brooklyn brooklyn
new york and uh tell me about your
family growing up you had mom and dad
yeah my mother
my pops he was doing him he was getting
money
you know what did your dad do for money
got money yeah
he was a panamanian in new york in the
in the 70s and 80s so you do the math
yeah i made it
but he got a lot of money
good childhood
for the most part
i mean
i grew up in
brooklyn in the
80s and 90s the birthplace of crack and
all that so it was about as good as it
could be watching you know
your neighborhood turn to [ __ ]
so you're you took to the streets early
yeah what kind of
kind of we kind of all really did like
you know man like if you was
i say all real street dudes started
early all that coming in the streets
when you're like 30 30 coming away
like whatever you've been doing for the
past few years like you should stick to
that like
by the time i was
eight nine years old
man my little cousin was i mean my older
cousin we were breaking into houses
you know we broke into the plugs house
one time and he thought it was his girl
and beat the [ __ ] out of him
[Laughter]
yeah he thought that was his shorty
cause we broke him we climbed the
telephone pole and went over that [ __ ]
was dangerous went over to the window
and uh went up in there and we just took
stuff we didn't even know what it was we
were taking drugs we took money
but he ended up thinking that it was his
girl man beat the dog [ __ ] out of it we
heard it outside he was beating the hell
out of her
uh
but i was like eight nine
then from there it was whatever you know
how did you get introduced to the game
the game
the game was always around me you know
for various sources
in new york well brooklyn at the time
you had like different types of
underworlds you know what i mean
you had the stick up kids
uh uh it wasn't really a lot of scamming
back then it was you know the stick-up
kid the africans were scamming
you had uh car thieves i mean a lot of
car thief crews
you had the uh boosting crews
and certain crews just moved in the same
circles so you know like the
big drug dealers pimps rappers they
moved into cert certain circles because
they was the ones that was getting money
so
i was what the drug dealers at first you
know i mean
and
one of my og's one of my mentors
he kind of
he kind of told me
that uh i could be doing other things it
wasn't like i wasn't making money i was
making a bunch of money
but
you know he was like
it started that it started at a strip
club we was at the strip club we just
got paid
i was doing insurance for all this some
[ __ ] right there
and these paychecks was was decent 15
bands 10 bands a week or so
and we up in the strip club my uncles
and i'm over there
bmf and blowing money fast all over the
place
pop pulled me to the side and he like
listen i want to talk to you
this old man kept me at the bar and just
talked to me the whole time i'm watching
them over there having a ball they over
there wow and girls everywhere
so i'm sitting there out of respect
talking to pops
then at the end of the night he just
stopped with the jibber jab in the
[ __ ] he was really just stalling me
to so i didn't go over there with them
and at the end of the night
funny i just spoke to the guy who this
happened with he uh at the end of the
night he said now this is the good part
it was just chick
um
that my uncles would never have been
throwing mad money on he said now you
see that girl right there that pretty
little red bone right there he said she
bout to go over here and give
all
my son and your stupid-ass uncles money
to this guy over here this the good part
and i watch her go over there and just
go she had the tall boots on she went in
the boots
started pulling out all this money
and just like checked it in and out like
this he said now
if you want to go give away your money
just go give it the old boy he said you
can get smart
so what's the difference between you and
him
he said you have all them girls coming
by the house all the time and
but you still out here hustling and
running around with guns and
like need to chill
so one day
i took a device
it's a better lifestyle right safer
i ain't nothing safe about it yeah i
mean
that's a misconception
ain't no safety in this
you know
that's why you got these young cats
they're coming around now all they see
is the glitz and glamour
you know
they see the
big cars and
houses and
you know
all the irrelevant [ __ ]
but
when i called my case i was looking at
174 years
174 years yeah so that part how safe
that [ __ ] feel
i'd have been better off
i could actually shot like three people
and
and not been looking at that much time
see i'm saying so
it's not real safety
you gotta
back back when i was heavy in the game
you know it was a lot of
traveling with females
wearing a bunch of jewelry fur coats
luxury cars and strange towns
so you know
how safe is that
you've been out of prison for how long
22 months
you do how long how much seven and a
half years seven and a half years
so you you kind of transitioned into
this this that new hustle
at what age
okay we're talking like 96
98 heavy like going into the 2000s heavy
i was dabbling
in the 90s
but i had such a mean catch on that my
dabble was different than other people's
devil like for me dabbling was having
three chicks making a bunch of money but
i was getting a lot of money doing my
other stuff that the game money didn't
impress me
you know and i was making money you know
but the game hadn't yet impressed me
it was only when
i just started focusing on the game
then i seen okay well you could take it
to the next levels and
you know
next thing you know you got
a house with an elevator in it
and exotic wildcats running through the
house i mean
monkeys and chinchillas and iceberg kind
of [ __ ]
that was the thing though you know how
exotic how rare
how different
yeah i mean
it was really about
you know
guys who really did it like when we was
doing it
because you know now
you know
i'm what they call an og a dinosaur like
you know i'm retired you know i'm
i'm the guy i'm the guy that a lot of
guys is running my old place
you know i mean like i'm
i'm like popovich or something like that
you feel me holy
how old am i yeah 44 well i'll be 44 in
a couple days
you're not that old
for the streets man listen i got shot
when i was 19.
flatlined and all that you ain't
supposed to be here so for the streets
44 i'm a senior citizen in my hood you
know what i'm saying
i got cousins that died at 23 24 i got a
lot of great friends like from 2001 to
2003 i went to like 23 funerals
a lot of people was getting killed so
you know i'm seeing a citizen in the
streets
you know a lot of us don't make it that
far
to be on the streets you know what i
mean streets of new york are similar to
streets in l.a same same story
yeah and no see new york i make a
distinction i'm from brooklyn it's a
difference
it's a big difference between brooklyn
harlem and queens you know we dealt with
a grittier reality
our [ __ ] was more in your face you know
brooklyn was where you could really
come to die you feel me
like the blocks i grew up on was
notorious like
you know for like
brutal [ __ ] like
you know i seen somebody get their head
blown off and i was like six seven years
old in the 80s
you know man
like
mobile police stations parked on
on the corner and you got cops like if
there's an intersection there's two cops
here two cops dead two cops eight cops
for the intersection
you feel me
cameras on light poles and
tnt squads
you know so it was a different
reality
for us at that time
whereas though
in other places in the city these guys
was getting money it wasn't that cash in
brooklyn wasn't getting money it was
just that everybody wasn't getting money
so when he was up in harlem in queens
there was a lot of dudes out in these
places getting a lot of money
so
they should look different
brooklyn it was only select few that was
getting money
so you're around woes you're around
lions you're around
you're around people you're around to
have nuts so they want what you got
so
to like wear diamonds and jewelry and
drive luxury cars you got to be a
certain type of dude before i'm saying
like you couldn't just be no sucker
getting money in brooklyn you know
like
that that flash is almost flaunting it
in the face of everyone i'm from tuck
your chain land and that ain't about
being a punk that's you don't keep
waving steak in front of wild animals
and expect nothing to happen to you
not unless you just want to walk around
with your gun out all day and that's
kind of corny if you're trying to get
money
so you know we used to pull our chains
out of the club and you know we flossed
the club you know but we got guns
stashed behind dumpsters i remember
going to stash my gun behind the
dumpster one day and it was already two
guns behind me i was like oh half night
you know like but you know putting guns
in wheel wells or cars that was close to
the front door of the car to the to the
club
that was how we had to move
you know
just to go to the club for the weekend
and hope all of us make it back home
because the shootout was definitely
going to happen
clubbing in brooklyn
somebody was shooting it's like
it was just when the shootout happened
did we get to do the whole party or was
it after you know
but you know that that was the reality
of what i grew up in
you know the game has changed over the
years right
i don't even respect what they call the
game nowadays that's why i ain't proud
of it like i'm cool
you know it um
it's sad what's going on now
and i say that because
see when i when i was coming in the game
we had love for each other we was all
getting money
you know it's a lot of money floating
around
um it's about real money like playing
even broke dudes getting real money like
you know
um
and it wasn't all the disrespect and
these guys went around here
disrespecting each other they got these
girls doing all these weird drugs and
you know and then they don't do nothing
for the females that they're dealing
with like
your female was always your status
symbol
so
if you was a high level
asset out here
they could tell by yeah shorty you know
she was
she was something different
you know like when she was out there
moving and grooving
we had our females jumping out of range
rovers and
you know i mean porsches and
like some cats had them in rolls royces
you know i mean
like minks to the floor you know iced
out watches
you know like
really like they look like nba wives
as they should
now these shorties be looking like
junkies and yeah you know like i i have
yet to see
uh
a movement where there's guys out here
actually caring about what they doing
now it's just about being loud annoying
making noise and disrespecting other
people the females don't even understand
why they in the game yeah everyone looks
pro
yeah you know like
and the funny thing is i be you know a
lot of dudes reach out to me og mentor
me or whatever whatever
and
you know i don't waste my breath on a
lot of dudes because i got other things
to do but there's some cats that i
actually see
um
they got potential to do things
so i mentored them outside the game
you know
i'll be telling them uh hold on one
second i'll be telling them about this
uh
i'll be telling them about crypto
you know what i mean
and i'm about to check mines right quick
see that see that's what you put your
money in where you can wake up every day
look see 14 15 20 grand see i got a new
hustle
said take a couple three grand here four
grand here throw it in the market
you know what i mean so
when dudes be asking me to mentor them
that's where i take it from you know
what i mean like yo you got any crypto
you like you diversifying your life
think about life outside of the game
see the game is cute you know there's a
lot of guys in the penitentiaries ask me
oh man big dog show me
and i just always tell them my man you
know what the punchline of this joke you
asking me about is where we at
we sit here in the day room in prison
i i you know like i had to pay
a lot of money and a lot of stress and
that i put on my family and my i had a i
had a kid that had just been born you
know while i was in jail
and
i'm in i'm in prison now you feel i'm
saying [ __ ] all the money [ __ ] the
maseratis the poor [ __ ] that this to
that that man [ __ ] all that you know
what i'm saying
that [ __ ] don't mean nothing when you
sitting in prison everybody ordered the
same 150 bag
a [ __ ] food and now this is money
this food is money
somebody will come [ __ ] you up for a bag
you know because you owe them 10 bags of
chips and
some fish pouches yeah man so it's a
different
reality when you hit prison you know
what i mean
and a lot of cats don't prepare for
outside of the game
so when prison hit them they done [ __ ]
up their money on worthless useless [ __ ]
you know they just want to take pretty
pictures for instagram
you know
and the females are so goofy
while your daddy is taking the pretty
pictures on instagram
your pictures look weird
you know
all your pictures got you in like
light up heels and
stripper outfits in the middle of the
street
that wasn't fly [ __ ] like
in my ever we didn't that wasn't
you wouldn't even let your people get
filmed like that yeah i mean wouldn't
let her post a picture like that
wouldn't let her put herself out there
like that because that's representing
you
you know these [ __ ] be out there with
like eight dollars worth of clothes on
rice that you know
my people used to go out there like
really looking different
but
i'm the king of midtown this is midtown
you talking about you can't go out there
looking weird you feel what i'm saying
like
you got to look like you belong in
midtown this midtown manhattan that's a
lot of money around here you feel me
everywhere they go it's those voices
uh
[Music]
diplomats
you wouldn't believe the people that
come through the door man like
and you know you get a call you wouldn't
believe who i'm here with who
i'm like all right cool you know like
but it was the everyday thing in midtown
to make 10 15 20 000 in the night was
really nothing
you know
so
we moved at a different pace
you know now these kids is they got this
thing called quota as long as they make
a thousand dollars they they are happy
they are
and then they go blow 600 out of a
thousand because they got to live in the
hotel and pay for the rental and
everybody got to eat and then they got
to pay for everybody's various drugs and
by the time we took care of the drug
habits and the food and all that
i need y'all to go out and get some more
money that's right you know what i mean
before i beat you up and and that's
another thing now you know they want to
beat these broads up and
that was what we call running out of
pimping
like you got to beat the [ __ ] up dad
you couldn't talk to her like you know
one of my mentors told me he said listen
if you ain't had to beat the [ __ ] up to
get out here you you shouldn't have to
beat up to get her to do what she need
to do you feel me
so
i always stuck with that
so
when
you
ready to choke out or kick ass and all
that you running out of game like fast
as fast as you get mad and getting up
you running out of game right now
this is this is a representation of you
this is somebody that's in your
household so after you beat up then
you're gonna send out there
now everybody's gonna say damn he'd be
beating the [ __ ] out he's been like it's
not a good look
you know that's not
ain't no prestige in that you know
and you know you don't get no points for
that
do you think the game is fading away
it's overrun with these
low-level streets house
faded away the game would never go
nowhere i mean let's just be honest
prostitution zone yeah i mean
nah see prostitution ain't the game
prostitution is the act that females do
while they out there yeah i mean and out
of the game prostitution right solutions
not the game
you feel what i'm saying
i don't know [ __ ] prostitution
[ __ ] prostitution and i mean the game
is the game the game got rules the game
got principles
before them saying like prostitution
will always be around but that's not the
game
see the game is when you take a female
or set a female
and put them
with a king you know i mean you take
some queens and put them what they can
well they're not even queens when they
show up a lot of times that's the king's
job you know i mean i always tell people
kings make queens
i mean even in old times like a queen
could be whatever but she had to marry
and make it because
the empire could not be ran without a
king
you know i mean if you're a chess player
you know the queens all the queen's
moves is in protection of the king
you feel me and if you push the right
pawns forward you have as many queens on
the board as you want
i mean so they come as pawns and you
make them queens but these [ __ ]
nowadays they take them where they at
and [ __ ] them up even more
like y'all ain't even trying to build
nobody i ain't even trying to help
nobody you know ain't like
you just wanna you know
bring everybody over to your crib with
your three five bedrooms and run it like
a halfway house
hey you want a room
go over there and that's your room
bro this is i mean
i wasn't raised in the game like that
you was always supposed to be able to
sustain a household in the bank road
that went for every female
she got to maintain this household
that's everything that comes with this
household
the bills the um and a bankroll you know
i mean
that's how that household grows in this
household well it's a team effort but
just like on every team the players
don't go home together we come to the
game we can't show up at the game we
play our ass off and then we go to our
separate residences so we can live our
lives
man man but when we show up on the court
and we show up at the game we're all
ready to play the game
you know together as a team a lot of
times the members don't even get along
you know
kobe and shaq didn't get along but boy
do they get they have action they made
money they bought championships i got to
be your friend to win with you you know
a lot of these dudes is more interested
in
what it looked like than what it
actually is
they rather
look good on camera than be good in real
life
that's why i tell dudes you know my real
life is better than the fake one you
made up for yourself on instagram
you know and a lot of cats don't don't
get that like what you see with big
knowledge is what you get
you know i don't do no action because i
don't give a [ __ ] about what people
think
i mean i say what i feel
you know i mean if it's real it's real
if it's wrong it's wrong because
righteous is righteous i mean
a lot of these dudes are just part of
the part of the pack you know they go
along with the flow what do you what do
you live by that separates you from the
pack i live by the cold like it's really
a cold
you know
you don't tell on your friends
you know i mean you don't [ __ ] on your
friends
the whole team eats
you know
this is these is the the principles that
came [ __ ] the game that's the code of
the streets
you feel me anybody on the team eat that
was all all the successful crews you saw
it was where everybody could pull up in
a fly whip and everybody had a nice crib
and everybody had bags of money like
even back to the supreme team and
uh the frittata all these big drug crews
from back in the day
everybody had money that's what made it
work you know when it's just one guy
sitting at the top and everybody else
look like they're struggling how'd that
look
that's not a strong team that's a strong
individual you know my uncle taught me
that
when he starved the whole team out
and i used to just see how it was
another crew and when these dudes when i
was doing the shimmers frog when these
dudes used to pull up
they used to look different when they
pulled up you feel me
like they used to look real different
like
benz's trucks fall from me we all ride
him with this [ __ ] he first said cause
he took all he done he shorted us on all
our money
and uh played us
so we can't afford the nice car
we can't afford to do this and that
you feel me
and i just used to see
how much better
the winning team looked
as a part of the winning dude
so i'm saying we used to go to the club
we couldn't we never had nowhere for
chicks to fit
we fought deep and escalate what the
[ __ ] we gonna take chicks at these other
[ __ ] they packing them in yeah we got
room in the bins we got room in the
lexus they packing them in and sliding
up out the club
so you know what i mean but that's that
big me little you mentality
that bring down empires
there's a lot of that flaunting that
goes on in the black
culture
well and a lot of it's i think just
it's just in the in in the hood for sure
culture it's because
you grow up and i have it that's what it
is this is the things you see these are
the things that you
aspire to these are the things that you
associate with money
it's breaking that
thought pattern for people that helps
you create
generational wealth it's knowing that
the game
is a tool
it's not a
career it's not a you know i mean
it's a catalyst it's full to take you to
the next level
it's something you're supposed to
use as a foundation for the next level a
lot of people don't think about the next
level
it says right now self-gratification is
gone we're moving we're shaking and i
mean i could post some weird pictures
and say some some some some funny [ __ ]
and yeah sound cute
you feel what i'm saying but
what's the reality of that
what's the uh
what's the outcome
you know i was always taught garbage in
garbage out you know what i mean you put
garbage into a [ __ ] that's all
you're gonna get out of it you feed your
body garbage expect to look like [ __ ]
you know man
so don't expect nothing good to happen
when from your situation when you don't
have
nothing good going on with your
situation
i mean
a lot of these dudes
be [ __ ] on these females and then
they'd be like oh man she's a punk she's
a dead she's a that come on bro
she's a punk
you're whipping this bra's ass taking
the money ain't that [ __ ] for and then
when she stop [ __ ] with you or you
gave her one ass open too much and she
said you know what i gotta get away from
you and she went to the police yeah i
mean and they'd be like oh she's a
snitch she's a chick you know man she's
about 120 pounds and
she's terrified and she knows that these
[ __ ] with these badges and guns
can get your ass the [ __ ] away from me
right now i'm tired of taking these ass
opens because you [ __ ] up the money
at the casino i'm probably taking these
ass weapons cause you got a percocet
happy i'm tired of taking these ass
opens because you want to shop every
week so you got forty thousand dollars
worth of clothes but you ain't never had
forty thousand dollars worth of cash
you know man
but
you wanna keep [ __ ] her up or
blacking out on her because you [ __ ]
up the money
you know so that leads to indictments or
chicks just not [ __ ] with you and
seeking a better life elsewhere but then
dudes want to be like oh man she ain't
[ __ ]
she's a [ __ ] she's a punk
i can't really say that you know
oh man all these [ __ ] is all render
gigs ain't [ __ ] with no pimps a lot
of broads just don't want to [ __ ] with
child [ __ ]
it's not like they don't want to uh a
[ __ ] that's in their corner they
don't want a p they don't want a
gentleman that's gonna be silent for him
but they just know y'all not that
you know they could tell by your track
record they can see by what you've done
you know so
you got a lot of females out here that's
just
they outlaws they're running outside the
game doing what they do
pig farmers as we call them
they feel me they just out here
doing their thing but it's not because
see the difference between what they
call renegade now and abroad that just
don't want to [ __ ] with nobody right now
it's not that she don't want to [ __ ]
with nobody she just ain't found
somebody genuine that she really sees is
gonna have her best interest at hand
that she sees a bright future with
like because i know some chicks that
leave the last dude and just do way
better by their self
and then go back and get with the
[ __ ] and lose a little bit of
[ __ ] they got when they was on their own
because even with a starter kit a lot of
these [ __ ] can't do [ __ ]
you know there's no vision
but they got that ao beat that all on
the [ __ ] mentality and
it's not really how i go
it's like you don't take the [ __ ] money
and blow it
and come back and say hi [ __ ] come on
let me see mo bring me some more it's on
you yeah that's right i [ __ ] up 2000
at the casino [ __ ] go give me some more
and the sad part is there's way too many
females out here that just accept that
and they really think that that [ __ ] is
cute i'm like this
that's a damn shame you like really
you like flaunting his stuff they be all
up in they do call taking pictures
that's not your life though when you're
done with you the car gonna stay you
walking and he'd probably take you a
little bit of clothes that'd get you and
give it to the other chick that's the
new thing too
give the old clothes to the new [ __ ]
there's a lot of not knowing your value
out here
that's why these females ain't making
the right decisions
yeah if you don't know your value as a
female you'll settle for anything
i know my value that's why i don't
settle for anything what role models did
you have as a kid
growing up
my grandpops my pops
um were they hustlers
yeah
my grandpa uh local loan shop
and the church guy
and
my pops was my pops like
and he kind of legendary himself
my pops are different because he made
two legends one in the streets and one
in the uh
fashion world
it's different my pop's got a mean
bloodline for real you have kids
i got five kids
and you're raising them of course
the difference between having kids and
being a father like i got yeah
i take care oh my
you know three i'm grown so
there's that right and when i'm in
prison he went to prison while i was in
prison
uh
the other one just turned 18.
he's about to be 19.
and then my other son
his mom went to jail while i was away
and she lost him so i'm still trying to
figure out where he at and then i lost
contact with her again so
there's that you know man and you're
your grandsons that are not in prison
are in the streets or they're doing
something well i got a baby that's a
young boy he's a few months and then i
got my daughter
she's eight
and uh
yeah she's doing a thing you know good
student yeah
um daddy's girl
spoiled right
but i was spoiling her from from jail
like i was sending her
uh thousand dollar gifts from credit
like so you know
i kind of i kind of did a lot for her
because you know compensate for me not
being there so now she's like a little
daddy's little princess type of type of
deal
you know
what separates a successful hustler
from a low level discipline
a lot of these people don't have
discipline
you know they too in a rush
to show off
like for the same dude that seemed big
knowledge in the
trucks i came in the game i had a
navigator with a bunch of tvs in it like
crazy system
uh i said i had money i was already
getting money i was doing everything
but it was the discipline like
i slept on the a train before
i slept on park benches you feel what
i'm saying
i slept on the park bench in my hood
and my brothers came out there i was
like why are you sleeping are you
sleeping on the
head like where everybody can see you
look at this my hood ain't nobody gonna
do nothing to me here i'm gonna stay
right the [ __ ] yeah and go to sleep
cause y'all just y'all see me you know
what i'm saying i get on the a train and
go all the way uptown and come downtown
and go all the way up to town do that
four times i got me enough sleep to get
back out there i used to do this for
four grand five grand in my pocket but i
knew i needed that four or five grand to
make other moves
you know i mean so i'm not in a rush
though
like you got people that save up to buy
jewelry like they'll take they'll save
up their little thirty forty thousand
dollars just to go buy some jewelry and
be broke again after my man
like
bro like that [ __ ] is really not that
relevant it's really not that serious
my man
i like just making money and keeping it
the fact of knowing that and this is
something somebody told me he said look
can you afford to buy it right now like
yeah he said can you afford to buy it
twice i said i could afford to buy it
three times he said well just knowing
that
should give you satisfaction
you don't actually have to see when you
go out there
and
the jewelry the cars the clothes all
that doesn't show how much money you
have that shows how much money you've
blown
you know i mean
that's not a hundred thousand dollar car
that's what you paid for you know it's
not a fifty thousand dollar chain that's
what you paid for it
so i tell do that all the time like oh
man you see i got the 20 000 on my neck
no
it's probably about six seven thousand
you got on your neck you had to pay for
the craftsmanship
i'm a jeweler
i'm not going to sell you the same
weight in gold for at price and i'm
going to do the work what do i get paid
for then i'm going to buy my gold i'm
going to melt it down i'm going to do
your designs i'm going to do your change
i'm going to do your logos i'm gonna do
all of that you're gonna pay me for my
craftsmanship i'm an artist
so that's what you're paying me for
now actual weight in gold and diamonds
it's gonna be a lot less than what you
paid for
so you just lost some money
you know i mean your brand new hundred
thousand dollar car loss
your 1200 shoes big loss stupid loss
i got 1200 on my feet no you don't the
guy you bought him from has 1200 in his
cash register
you have about
80 worth of material on your feet
and they beat you over your head with
the craftsmanship because the reality is
i'm a wholesaler to somebody you know i
got to have my margin on it so me as the
me as the uh
maker
i'm going to put it at a low enough cost
for somebody else to sell it for me and
they can add their price to it so people
want to see nice margins when they do
business so
i'm and i'm as the maker i'm trying to
get it done at the smallest price
possible you see what i'm saying
so when we're working like that you got
about eight dollars worth of material on
your feet that you gave somebody twelve
hundred dollars for so it's knowing
what's really relevant
is
what people in the game ain't getting in
the streets period
you know
it's knowing that
that [ __ ] you blowing your money on
trying to look like a rapper who talking
about the streets but he's not in the
streets
see he raps and gets 300 000 for a show
and then talks about street [ __ ] and he
takes the 300 000 that he got from the
show that your girlfriend went to
and he goes buys more this [ __ ] that you
really can't afford
you know and you breaking your neck
trying to live this life live this
facade
so that's what got the game broken right
now there's no values there's no cold
there's no morals
we got [ __ ] screaming we don't
love them hoes well why are you pimping
if you don't love hoes you should love
to [ __ ] out them hoes man
the hoes love you
you know what i mean you don't love the
hoes like wow that's like being a drug
dealer saying i don't like drug users
like what
how are you going to make money
you know
then you abuse your source of income you
abuse the income that came from your
source of income
you know so it's a whole pattern of
abuse
that probably started with patterns of
abuse from when a lot of these guys was
raised up but you know these chicks is
out here with the crack babies you know
a lot of these guys out here now is was
born in the crack ever
you know their parents wasn't around i
mean [ __ ] your mom or your dad not being
around a lot of people know what they
feel like they was raised in foster
homes
so their value system is [ __ ] up but
they was raised by the system so it was
a whole lot of pain and abuse that came
from the system
and they just
you know
give it back
you know repeat the pattern
yeah and
it was
i say my generation
we was the golden ever the golden ever
hip-hop the golden ever everything
you know like when you think about all
of the guys that's out now who are
rappers they always say they
they mention the the the rock chems and
this and that because these are the guys
that were real poets these were the guys
that was about they craft
you know
scarfaces these were the guys that was
telling the story and the pain from the
streets
so this is where they this is where they
got they
their their uh things from but then
that left
that sense of values left the streets
so now everybody just
man everybody out here now just want to
do drugs shake ass and kill that's this
whole generation doing drugs the [ __ ]
are shaking ass and the [ __ ] just
trying to kill each other
you know they idolize the shooter
the shooters are pawn on the board
the boss ain't doing the shooting you
telling me you a shooter let me know how
much money you're not getting
really you're the shooter i don't i
don't want the shooter hanging around me
the shooter is who i call to go
i look i'm gonna give you whatever you
feel as though your life is worth to go
handle this for me right quick
that's the shooter
it's no honor and being a shoot i came
up in the generation that bred the
bosses for them saying
biggie smalls and all these were bosses
these guys you looked at they was bosses
you know we emulated the boss the boss
image
these dudes running around looking weird
and on off drugs
if you're popping pills all day and
sipping lena you're a junkie my name
you not that
and you're shorty giving you this money
wondering why y'all not getting nowhere
because he's a junkie you remember
saying like this ain't that
you know you got to have discipline
that's what's [ __ ] the game up nobody
got discipline
without discipline there's disrespect
without order there's anarchy and chaos
you gotta have order
going to prison taught me that this
dudes i met in prison that i'm glad they
built prisons these dudes belong in
prison they belong in cages for the rest
of their lives
they've done some weird [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know what i mean
[ __ ]
weird [ __ ] to kids and old people and
women and just weird [ __ ] there's a
place for everybody there has to be
discipline there has to be law there is
no law there is no discipline and the
ones that are supposed to be enforcing
the law and the discipline they're going
with the flow they're making excuses
you know i mean
the black community the black man is
being
you know they taking the masculinity out
of the community they got these boys
running around here looking like sissies
and weirdos
and
if you don't go along with it you
homophobic nah listen
don't
really know a lot they think black men
in the culture is homophobic average
black dude don't give a [ __ ] what you do
who you [ __ ] who dick you suck in i
might give a [ __ ] about that just don't
[ __ ] with my money you know what i'm
saying that's how that's how real g's
give a [ __ ] you know that's what we
really care about don't [ __ ] with my
money
you know what i mean
so you could be whatever you want to be
however you want to be
you know i mean but when you start
promoting it to the to the degree where
it's affecting a culture and you're
making being a drug addict the norm all
the rappers is drug addicts so the kids
grow up to idolize these guys
all the rappers is you know
more effeminate now than they've ever
been so the kids growing up thinking
this is cool
i think it's taking the choice away
because the ones that are supposed to be
the role models and the heroes
these are the ones that's victimizing
these kids mentally right now
so the game is a product
of that
warren buffett said in five years you'll
be the
product of the books you read and the
people you surround yourself with
90 of these kids don't read books they
get all the information from it from the
internet
instagram
you know
that's what they call the news i saw it
on the gram all right whatever
that's what they think that's what that
that's what validates their life
instagram twitter
before i'm saying i don't take none of
that [ __ ]
as seriously as everybody else i live
i'm too rooted in
reality see when your reality is solid
that other [ __ ] is you realize how
irrelevant that other [ __ ] is
you know
you realize how irrelevant that goofy
[ __ ] is when
your reality is solid you know i don't
drive rental cars
you know i don't do nothing i can't
afford to do
i don't mistreat my my females
before i'm saying that was never my
thing
you know that's why every female that
dealt with me still [ __ ] with me we
still friends we still cool
i still call and check on their kids see
how everybody's doing
i mean i still you know
am interested in what happened with
their life because the time we spent
together and whatever we did when we was
doing whatever we was doing
it meant something you felt i'm saying
you wasn't just a
a piece
uh a cog in the wheel as they say that
when it broke [ __ ] replace the wheel
now you what we did meant something we
was building an empire everybody don't
always see eye to eye
you know just like a basketball team
they have their little dynasty years and
then people go to get traded they go
other places that don't mean that it's
not still love there that don't mean
that it's not still that bond that
yeah remember when we got them five
championships you know i mean so it's
always gonna be that love even for
brothers i don't
exactly see eye to eye with a like
anymore
you know what i mean i respect what you
did while you was here
i don't have no animosity toward anybody
that i've dealt with i don't hate nobody
i ever dealt with
you know what i mean because
it was love while you was here you know
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
learning what to place value on
you know
a lot of these kids out here will never
experience the type of money i've
experienced
i had two twenty thousand dollar cats
you know what that is like and and then
i had some ten thousand dollar dogs
you know what i'm saying a fleet of cars
outside like half a million dollars in
cars that's my half an hour on cars
a lot of people will never experience
that but see once you bought everything
you got all the you went to the shoe
store and you got all everything that
you ever you didn't did all that right
you don't travel you done
and you're still just making this
[ __ ] money
that's when you start doing crazy [ __ ]
that's why you see rappers with cheetahs
and all that cause they just [ __ ] it i
want to buy it cause i can afford it
because at that point money becomes
irrelevant
when you used to get money it starts to
become irrelevant it's like all right
well yeah i made some more money
you feel me
the money really becomes irrelevant
so then you learn going to prison tells
you what's really valuable because once
they took the cars and all that [ __ ] and
i'm sitting in here doing my time
but i'm getting press pictures of my
daughter
people was dying
you know i mean people that was fine
when i went home they sick now
that's the [ __ ] the money ain't gonna
pay for
i don't bought new cars and
cribs and you know
trinkets and you know [ __ ] that's
replaceable
but you know my cousin that died while i
was gone before i had time to make
amends
for some [ __ ] we was going through i
can't get that back you feel sad
it's my cousin he died and we was really
and we was beefing over some [ __ ] that
we shouldn't even be beefing over
i ain't gonna get a chance to fix that
[ __ ] all right
so that's what life is really about
knowing what's valuable knowing what has
value and once you learn that
then you learn
what not to
hold in such high regard
so i'm saying like
you learn what not to
place so much
energy home
you know
if you're a stand-up dude
and not just in the streets just as a
man if you're a stand-up man
you've got the best interest for the
people around you
you don't [ __ ] over your friends you
don't [ __ ] on the people that's loyal to
you and good to you you know we had a
rule spoil the loyal
when you're that type of individual
life treats you good
you don't have a lot of regrets
even if you go to prison or whatever
whatever
you still cause while we in prison we
sit and looking at the books
like yeah it's like yeah none of us want
to end up in prison but
you really gonna say you didn't have fun
while you was doing it you feel me like
it's a roller coaster we enjoy the highs
and the lows you know what i mean
but
would you change it no you learn from it
you know if you're the same man at
30
that she was at 20 you wasted 10 years
of your life
and the same thing proceeds up the
ladder
it's a growing process and it makes you
demand like it all has a build up like a
movie
you know you it starts here
in the growing pains and this that is
dirty then you get your values and your
principles
my pops taught me the biggest value and
i don't even think he know he did that
when i was a kid and my mom's and him
was going through something and they
tried to take me from my father
and we was running through a parking lot
and duel link
the dude my mother was dating
and my pops man
my problem like slipped and he was
holding me like this and i'm looking up
at him you know because i'm like this
and he hold me like this and dude got a
gun in my pocket's head
but my pot my my fam got the gun in his
head my pop said
what you waiting for shoot him
and he said listen
johnny i got the gun cop he got he got
his gun cocked if i shoot him
he's going to kill you
my pops looked at
me kissed me
and said man shoot him anyway
you feel me
that told me die for what you believe in
at the end of the day he wasn't about to
fold
and i mean and when he kissed me he
kissed me with all the intensity of this
might be the last time i see my son but
when that dude
seeing how far my father was willing to
go for what he believed in
that was when he backed off
because when you're dealing with a man
that's willing to die for his principles
then that shows where you stand on yours
you know
all right big knowledge thank you so
much for
sharing your story man very interesting
thank you very much
you